here's Peter Ducey from Fox asking Kirby
once again here's Kirby again if Putin
and G fear Joe Biden Russia and China it
seems like this these two superpowers
are teaming up now against the US why
did President Biden let this happen
Peter
these are two countries that have
long chafed as I said to Jeff longchafed
at U.S leadership around the world
um and uh
and the network of alliances and
Partnerships that we have this is not
this is not something that these two
countries just cooked up since President
Biden got elected it is something that
they have been since he's been president
he has talked tough he tried to pressure
Putin and she uh to act right or risk
their standing on the world stage does
he see now that they don't care
I think if you ask a lot of Russians
they certainly care I mean this their
economy is is uh barely being propped up
by some pretty radical measures by by Mr
Putin their military has uh been uh
roundly embarrassed inside Ukraine
um and they continue to lose uh ground
there do you think that Putin and she
fear President Biden
you'd have to ask them whether they fear
or they not it is not about fear it's
about President Biden advancing our
foreign policy goals around the world
it's about President Biden revitalizing
these alliances and Partnerships it's
about President Biden and what he's
doing to preserve our national security
interests around the world that's what
we're focused on it's just meaningless
dribble if they fear you they might
actually do some of the things you want
it's not about fear it's about President
Biden making sure he can put his shoes
on which I'm pretty sure you can't even
do that it's just
endlessly every that's what I'm trying
to show you guys at every level of this
government whether I'm showing you
things from Karen Jean-Pierre or we're
showing you Janet Yellen or we're
showing you John Kirby or we're showing
you mayorcus at the border every single
one of these people is unqualified to do
their job so we'll get into the 2024
thing in a second but whether you like
Trump or you like DeSantis or you like
Nikki Haley or vivec you must vote for
these people you must support these
people we have to remove this
Administration that is actively
destroying our country basically at
every possible turn
foreign
[Music]